[Musique]
les essentiels du Sénat
anct se mettre au diapason des élus
locaux
connaissez-vous la NCT si vous répondez
par la négative c'est aussi le cas de
plus de la moitié des élus locaux
consultés sur la plateforme du Sénat en
2017 le président de la République avait
annoncé la création de l'Agence
nationale de la cohésion des territoires
en vue d'accompagner les collectivités
dans la définition de leurs projets
territoriaux notamment en matière
d'accès aux soins d'accès aux services
publics de logements de mobilité et de
développement économique durable en
octobre 2022 la délégation aux
collectivités territoriales avait lancé
une évaluation de la NCT
l'objectif analyser la perception de
l'agence par les élus locaux et évaluer
sa réelle plus-value pour les
collectivités territoriales après de
nombreux déplacements et auditions
Charles gainer et Céline Brulin ont
publié leur apport
ils font le constat d'un besoin d'aidect
qui reste prégnant sur les territoires
les rapporteurs relèvent un jugement
critique des élus locaux sur l'agence
sur trois points
l'implication des préfets en matière de
soutien des projets des élus locaux est
très inégales d'un département à l'autre
et ne va pas assez dans le sens de
soutien aux écosystèmes de proximité
l'approche de l'agence est peu attentive
aux dynamiques locales
enfin la promesse de simplification des
procédures et de soutien financier au
projet loco n'est pas tenu la mission a
élaboré des recommandations allant dans
le sens d'un rapprochement de l'agence
avec les élus locaux elle doit se mettre
au diapason de leurs besoins les
rapporteurs demandent à la NTT de porter
ses efforts sur l'accès des
collectivités à l'ingénierie
territoriale la mission préconise de
remobiliser et d'accompagner les préfets
sur leur mission de déléguer
territoriaux de l'agence le rapport
propose également que le sous-préfet
d'arrondissement deviennent
l'interlocuteur de premier niveau sur
les questions d'ingénierie orientation
relais des offres suivi des projets
enfin la mission préconise d'appuyer les
dynamiques existantes plutôt qu'en créer
de nouvelles et de soutenir la logique
de coopération entre différentes strates
de collectivités plutôt que des
approches par strat
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]